[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
see that dude beat that dude
No
[Music]
why
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
go to get Belleville calm / Hannibal and
get 10% off your first purchase that's
get bevel dot-com / Hannibal it's bet if
you got a garbage raise his way better
than if you got a good razor this is a
great razor so step up your razor plate
and go through you get somebody some
stuff for the holidays ha ha ha that's
not good fake laugh anyways get bevel
comm slash Hannibal 10% off
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
it's another episode another episode
[Music]
where downtown Chicago I'm your host
[Music]
Burress I'm your co-host
Tony trap we get a special guest on tour
with a gig later at the Aragon Ballroom
I'm plugging it like it's gonna help the
show's already sold out
and this hit might not even come on yeah
come on down two weeks in the past LP a
joke
how's it going it's good man you get to
put this thing in front of me no it's
[ __ ] up have you used that before I
have yeah it's been a minute though it's
one of those things that you body you're
really psyched about for like three days
yeah then it just kind of sits in your
studio for a year or two but yeah you're
bringing me back it's a fun machine I
got using this one over here you know
what you just haven't heard my good
stuff
I was I was saving it for the actual
show you know it was just like the one
line check hold up oh okay I think we
figured that out everything on this is
designed to make German trance in the
German disco kicking it dancing into the
early morning at 7:00 a.m. gonna grab
some skulls go grab some stones give a
party y'all
the party become Brasserie scowls Berlin
nightlife yeah would you like a scone
get me two you know what I'm on
give me two stones give me some coffee
I'm a Dibble Marlowe
ate half a skull damn I Nev you really
want those skulls that much no that [ __ ]
was kind of help
skulls are not really a German thing I
don't think look I look like Carmen
Sandiego
know about the world I don't know about
the world I don't know about the world
oh I think I think it's important though
it's you know so just just to talk about
it yeah I mean just cuz I get some pad
thai in Chicago don't make it Bangkok
yeah you know say I've heard that
expression my grandmother used to say
sweet country wisdom how's it going man
oh it's good man yeah it's good I guess
I had two weeks at home which was really
confusing for me because I haven't had
two weeks at home in 2017 yet
what'd you do at the time do you feel
disoriented a little bit yeah I just
stayed home I just literally stayed home
and the whole time and ordered food
what's happening man sound like the
appropriate the appropriate entrance
tonight
we're good man put those on and play
this you got your mic over there I think
this should be a mic over there for you
okay you hear us okay on there all right
yeah I just stayed the [ __ ] home and it
seems like when you get back to New York
you're like really excited about it you
know like I'm back in New York and all
my friends and I'm gonna go to max fish
you know you know it's like and you do
that like once you know and then you and
then you just hide for the time I
basically have just been smoking weed
and eating Chinese food in my apartment
not answering my phone I'm seeing I mean
I'm a bit on looks eat seamless three
emails famous caviar ya know this is
actually my girl I'm busting her right
now because I pay for it so I get the I
get the receipt so whenever my girl
orders something
yeah I'll just text her and be like how
was that breakfast burrito that I paid
for it while I'm on tour do you judge
the amount she tips do I judge the oh
you know what I really haven't peed that
I should look but she's a good tipper
she's she's she has plenty of service
industry experience well how much city
tip delivery you know man it's a debate
I don't really know but I tend to attend
oh I'm an over tipper when it comes to
people handling my food yeah because I
just figure it's already a shitty job if
you have yeah if you have the
opportunity to tip you should do it they
do have you know they're running around
they could be really fragrant with your
[ __ ] on the bike you know
you could get back you could get get the
food and a button of the packages could
be all [ __ ] up and open and [ __ ] cuz
they my I got my delivery tips usually
go like yo you smoke weed yeah here's a
joy yeah that's not bad it's pretty
that's pretty good I roll $20 joy so
it's a good - this is a $500 joint why
me I roll it grab a weed a gram a great
we - 20 bucks I'm I'm just bringing up
an old joke of ours oh yeah this is a
$500 the goal papers they gave ya they
give us uh they gave us was it gold leaf
yeah like 24 karat gold paper we all own
two times most expensive [ __ ] - killer
mykes third most expensive machine yeah
ya know but there's always something
weird about that like here burn this
gold yeah like he didn't didn't smoke
very dope either I don't actually smoke
I think I smoke that [ __ ] yeah I tried
it it didn't taste it didn't taste that
great yes si it's just a real letdown
phi3 it it it's just like hey look I'm
balling it's it's like that new pipe
they got to where it's like you load up
the weed and you smoke then you roll it
out and it's essentially a crack pipe
they like they've reissued the crack
pipe for a younger generation and pack
dudes it's great to see them like no
that's what your mom smoked in 88 when
she was partying with your uncle before
she dated your dad back story damn okay
so y'all have three apples because we're
smoking eight notches bad for smoked oh
I'm cool smoked dope I'm really cool ok
it was a new process of quitting you
know you know else quit smoking I was in
the process of saying he's quitting yeah
I support you it's not and I'm gonna
quit I have to quit I'm getting married
she told me that we're not getting
married on the side quit smoking which
of course is a [ __ ] reason to quit
but damn you should want to quit because
you don't want to die what was your
ultimatum like like you know how women
give you your ultimatum like you can't
you can't be [ __ ] on other women
anymore we're married like so what's the
guy ultimatum like you know I didn't
really have to tell me that particularly
she did that my wife had to say that to
me now that was that that was something
that I was pretty clear from the
beginning God I was fuzzy yeah I wasn't
I wasn't fuzzy on that I like smoking
it's the smoking yeah she's like you
have to yes you have to with basically
the whole your ultimatum no like if you
had ultimately I don't really she's a
you have to view and say like well you
got to put more [ __ ] paprika on your
chicken or I need extra sauce on my rice
because I'm giving up smoking like you
need another indulgence I feel
maybe murder work uh so we got a murder
someone every year together you got a do
it together
yeah I mean come on yeah that's what I
say it's alright I'll quit smoking but
you have to start coming out with me on
my murder sprees you know doing bixie
murder I mean you know it depends on
where I'm at you know it's a country
where yeah probably get away with it but
if you do without the libya's is that
where you cuz that one the black guy the
most dangerous game
okay so y'all got the album's run the
jewels one run the jewels tote boom run
the jewels three boom we work we were
playing around with calling it run the
jewels 5 joules 5 yeah what are you
actually kind of funny
yeah I'd like for I like Fortuna
we've already start for three and a half
just to [ __ ] with them yeah like jay-z
did blueprint 2.0 yeah yeah here's my I
think if you do five then people would
panic thinking that they missed out on
four and far less than City so it would
drive dreams for the other ones yeah
yeah marketing is key here it's a good
strategy in this age of this digital age
you know Oh name the tracks each name
the first track run the jewels for and
then so on and so forth up to like
running jewels 15 yeah yeah it's all
it's all on the table jewels as run the
jewels five and then release it as four
on vinyl but it's the same album hmm so
sex can the stereotypes of my agents and
their business mind thank you thank you
thank you
that is a compliment no it is no all the
Asian stereotypes tend to be kind of
[ __ ] good you don't know me
you know [ __ ] that small dick cheese
like they always assume you're the smart
guy in class right I love the fact that
as I was honest I was on the my wife and
I won't no piece of transportation
leaving the airport in Seattle and two
Asian guys came up and they were
laughing and joking tobacco us they said
ma'am
tie these why people just come up to me
ask me for direction the airport guy was
like what are you doing this guy looked
down just looked out and told my home
speak [ __ ] English as a black person
if I had the talent to do that in the
south you understand how many dumb ass
conversations I wouldn't have to have
with you can [ __ ] hillbillies
right because I'm black they know we all
do we know you only speak once I've done
that before actually when you do it you
put on like a real clothes we can do
like the closest people who do like you
know I guess Asian or something that
looks obviously like you might not speak
the language of America the closest you
can do maybe is just pretend to be deaf
yeah yeah you probably gotta push it a
little too far yeah keep doing that you
gotta keep that going I gotta watch you
got a walk-off you got a looking at the
back of your head to see if you gotta
sell it you know yeah like I don't
understand you're gonna be like you
haven't seen anything until you seen
death kids at an alternative school
fight what arguing we go downtown to
five points after school and there was
an alternative school for the bad kids
and the kids of you know turns and that
was a death alternative school so kids
who are death so it was like all right
you had to want to be gangbangers and
want to be cut rappers wanna be hustlers
wanna be and in there just be the circle
of kids that would definitely be
throwing their hands and flailing about
what the [ __ ] is going like at first you
thought there was throwing a gang
symbols and then every time someone
break out
oh hey you be like oh they're dead and
they be beefing and fighting that's how
I learned people are just people [ __ ]
your handicap
it was fighting over holes drinking 40s
smoking dirt we doing sign language yeah
shots out to my death thugs in Atlanta
in the night so I heard you may name the
company out there you close your eyes
when you a deaf person arguing with
another deaf person that's the ultimate
disrespect nah okay I can t see that
[ __ ] to talk about at least this is this
is turning into the least politically
correct conversation I've had in a few
weeks it's all fat people in black
people - not all people feel like they
can gotta get yeah hey man listen deaf
people I [ __ ] would you killer Mica's is
man and sensitive to your play that's
cool man but when you see Mike you know
yeah to me if you're mad I'll turn
around and see Mike it's it's just got a
feelin I actually hear this well yeah we
put titles
we'll put the videos up when you when
you do when you try to destroy when you
do that when you do that when you do
that impression that sounds like a seal
getting stabbed they're just gonna under
subtitle it's just gonna be like sorry
just for fun you guys can make a fat
joke though I don't mind it's fun
there's a beautiful child in this room
as we're doing this - I gotta say she's
what she's been chilling man she hasn't
said a word
she's like it's not really full
chuckling at all come here she's more
talented she's also not that interesting
yes she's like I want off of you know
she's like no not for you either what's
up
good 508 and we wanna know y'all done
with the for yet no hell no we haven't
even started oh cool so we can submit
for beat play yeah yeah I think this is
hey Tony let's just make a beats and get
on the album let's go hold on by the way
it took them 30 minutes to set this unit
just got started
yeah well that kind of sounds like a
prince
[Music]
[Music]
we got it down yeah okay we for a second
if you keep almost sounds like a prince
beat with coma sounds like sign of the
times you know sometimes I'll I'll see
different artists and musicians interact
with their with their friends yeah and
they'll say you know your music helped
me get through this I had some stuff
happening with my family and I was like
yo I really wanted to finish the last
part of this karate competition and then
I listened to y'all and then I broke six
boulders yes kind of yes we got a lot we
got a lot of weird we didn't like man so
many physical fitness people hit us in a
week I'm just like we got to do
something may I do the irony of run the
jewels music becoming like the number
one gym workout music of 2700 and and
who's making it has not escaped us like
it's so funny almost depressing everyone
said like we'll get a picture just like
just won a gold medal like just some
dude like ripped you know
[Music]
- girl when they roll I get a face
please play with all my business card
your luck I do two things I rap rap rap
I don't know man teach my hairy ass
thanks killer my canopy and we're just
sitting there with like crumbs on our
belly and like a joint in our hand like
well we did it again made the perfect
workout music yeah you guys do make
great workout music I honestly I
wouldn't know it's great for punching
heavy bags to punch heavy bags to your
music really having more put in my
basement this what happened it's not
something better when we used to oh I've
been on the road and being lazy and
getting fat again so yeah when I worked
out in February I listened to it yeah
what happens when you get to like the
depressing jams you know just slow the
pace down like damn I'm just thinking
about my dad yeah thinking about police
brutality we do get ill [ __ ] though
people you'd be surprised by when your
it went like and I don't know if this
has ever happened with musicians with
rappers if you say something you will
get some really like you kind of want to
not be affected emotionally by your
interactions by fans just because in
general you don't want to walk around
being like you no one wants to hear deep
[ __ ] all the times money only when they
just bump into somebody you know it's
kind of hard to know when it's gonna
happen ya know and you don't know where
you're it's like it's just gonna pop up
on you and you could just be thinking
about some completely different not
being the mood to talk to anybody and
then they'll say some really touching
[ __ ] and you'll just be caught off guard
like [ __ ] you know like wow I was really
hoping to not talk to you right now and
now you're gonna make me cry like it's
it's a weird situation and it's not that
you don't want to talk to people it's
just one of those things where you don't
know yeah you don't know you don't know
what's gonna come out of somebody's
mouth and sometimes it's as cool it's
just like hey man keep it up and
sometimes it's like I listen to this
song when I was you know as my mom was
dying when it got me through that you
know just some [ __ ] where you're like
you you know it really kind of makes you
wretches retro actively appreciate this
[ __ ] we're like there was no way in hell
that me and Mike are ever thinking in
our minds this song is gonna be listened
to while someone watches their their
best friend die
yeah yeah something like that and it
it's one of those things that I learned
young when I was like oh wait a second
once it's out there it's kind of not
yeah I don't know how people that's how
I feel with some people yeah listen to
your comedy even the ones about pregnant
I want to tell you story month
my uncle was dying I was there was very
rough you know he was going went through
a long period of decline and we just
kept reminding the Jews jokes over and I
gotta say it really brought him a little
extra life man that the compilation of
Hannibal Buress Jia's jokes thank you
and you know I just I appreciate that
and I'm sorry for what you went through
and I just yeah but nobody held really
my point is though on his deathbed my
uncle wrote a jizz joke for you and I
would really appreciate it if maybe you
would maybe let's hear me out
yeah and incorporated into into your set
it was actually his dying wish that you
did that tonight that's awesome so I'm
glad I'm here I'm so psyched I'm glad I
could make this happen
thank you thank you this actually bring
up microphone on a PA foot situation so
do [ __ ] like suggest jokes to
you and [ __ ] like poof like yo you
should talk about more jizz of which is
in a different way more kids you should
try this one try what is uh I'll just
have a normal interaction with somebody
well just buy something you know that'll
be 789 and I give them $10 and they'd be
like 211 change don't put this on your
standup what this normal interact this
regular [ __ ]
yeah I don't know how I don't know what
I fit Wow yeah that's the man I think my
God wasn't gonna do that now just chill
all right I'm just saying I want
royalties bad
at least you didn't get the to a
Christmas wrap do it do Thanksgiving
recommend Oh Mikey Mikey come on okay
get in the living room
Santa Claus my gifts to see I saw you
sucking on daddy's dick it's not right
huh no I mean look you're an artist
daddy loved it two gifts for great mommy
said thanks for getting us straight off
Santa Claus Santa Claus Victor balls the
Claus Santa Claus Santa Claus hey you
guys are nothing like to Neptune's
that's actually what thanks for ruining
my dream I love you guys I was like
somewhere somewhere Pharrell just woke
from a nightmare like I gotta make a
dopey there's a disturbance in the force
something terrible's be made I can feel
it
hey LPO I asked you a question
I heard I heard a story a friend of mine
was hanging out with you one night oh
and you don't try to break you my [ __ ]
you know I'm not you you randomly just
kind of looked up and was like this
place is haunted and you just kept about
going about what so like he he says that
you you can sense ghosts just randomly
no that's just like to throw people off
like
man so I just wait for my time and I
just go oh yeah you [ __ ] hearty this
place is haunted you just walk out and I
throw a little smoke bomb
so he's like yeah I think help he's got
a sixth sense he just sees Golson where
was it though I mean baby was just
somehow they said someone told me it was
haunted I don't have never seen a ghost
in my life
you guys were hanging out somewhere just
you out of I don't know where it just
was like already there's holes in your
story because I'm not just hanging out
with random dudes somewhere like that's
not that's not really what I do give me
more details this is like who's your
friend fish I taught my Brian you know
one day and he was just like you looked
up and to the side and was like this
place is haunted and that was it and you
didn't add anything to that
and then he was like I didn't have to
all-time great diarrhea cover-up yeah
yeah see ya later
that's what you say when you fart and
it's it's weird did you hear that I
heard this place is haunted
yeah I'm farting to scare these ghosts
away yes Island murder to Atlanta to
hear your average caught hour and a half
a silent murder yeah I am talking like
you know they were trying to figure out
if it was one of them doing it to each
other man you just have to do it I agree
I agree I agree I think you should if
you can fart styling this it's a
valuable weapon somebody I get hit so
everybody gets it yeah you can't feel
back as you get hit that's that's what
may I use to try to wait go to the
bathroom I'll [ __ ] that all white man
taught me when you're in the first class
the world is yours man take your shoe
off fart all that [ __ ] bro I'm living
like my name is Courtney
right or holes in my car no that's for
you I was reading no I went to this uh
this surgery Museum okay here in Chicago
and one of the exhibits it was this guy
I forget his name is doctor that was the
doctor that pioneered hand-washing
because before doctors weren't washing
their hands a lot of folks died and a
lot of folks died and so doctors were
we've come from working on cadavers and
then they would go deliver babies and
then these women would die yeah but then
he was saying hey we should start
washing our hands so less people died
hold on the French pioneer washing their
hands I'm these PS still don't do
deodorant all the way all right that's
the reputation okay elbows a little bit
like I'm an afro man on the train today
yeah plane yeah he's doing the players
ball tonight
I might go to see if he hits another
woman but ever Hezbollah Chicago now you
remember afroman was playing something
like some drunken white anglo-saxon
Protestant white woman start to hunch
him he didn't see like who it was Oh
grand up on stage a doctor [ __ ] out of
yeah he was scared for but has no title
you would like oh [ __ ] though you that's
kind of it you don't run up on
entertainer you do not run up on I scare
the [ __ ] out of those will you do that
well yeah we didn't own up together I
think it was 2013 South by Southwest 14
yeah was that the show were you at that
I wasn't at that show I was that we
didn't marry after that and I so
afterwards yeah
yeah you know very what a dollar that
[ __ ] rotator cuff that particular
situation it was a guy a schizophrenic
guy of course some some sort of some
sort of ailment some sort of malady
pretty pretty out of it that sucks
apparently yeah fun story but I do
remember that show and I had a giant
Mike's shoulder was [ __ ] up and I had
like a giant like basically like up like
a giant purple bruise on my belly from
falling on it's a metal [ __ ] and we were
and then we saw you we did that show
yeah it was alright - it's kind of a fun
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
get it poppin walk the patches run the
jewels Christmas
yo-chan around my house we're coming for
y'all man all right Chelsey all over
there man thanks guys yep
[Music]